[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOANNA SMITH: See?
It doesn't work.
COLT MCANLIS: That's weird.
Well, wait a minute.
No, those numbers
aren't exactly accurate.
JOANNA SMITH: No, that
is exactly accurate.
The bald guy in the
Compressor Head videos
told me that that
would be accurate
when he told me to
use variable length
codes for my
compression, that that
would give me close
to entropy, but what
I have here is nonsense.
COLT MCANLIS: OK.
Hold on.
OK.
So the algorithm's fine.
JOANNA SMITH: No, the
algorithm's not fine.
COLT MCANLIS: The date is set.
JOANNA SMITH: Your job
is to teach algorithms
and how are you still employed
here because this is bad.
This is a ignorant.
David Huffman would be turning
in his grave right now.
COLT MCANLIS: Ah, but you do
know who David Huffman is.
See, my job--
JOANNA SMITH: Oh,
so that's point?
The point is to learn names
and not to learn compression?
You're just name dropping now?
I thought you were going
to teach people algorithms.
I don't have time for bad ones.
COLT MCANLIS: OK.
We're competing with
cats on the internet.
We don't have the
full amount of time
to go through the algorithm--
JOANNA SMITH: To tell the story?
The punchline?
The thing that works?
COLT MCANLIS: We need to get
everything in one little--
JOANNA SMITH: Everything into
one video that be a complete
and teach people how to
do things because that's
your job, to teach.
Is it not?
COLT MCANLIS: OK.
So there's other
parts of the algorithm
that we didn't get a
chance to do last time.
JOANNA SMITH: The
people in the camera
need to know the
whole algorithm.
You need to tell them.
Tell them.
COLT MCANLIS: OK.
So what do you want me to do?
JOANNA SMITH: Tell them.
I want you to go and do
your job and tell them
exactly how to succeed
with compression.
COLT MCANLIS: Fair enough.
So--
JOANNA SMITH: Oh, wait.
No.
Your intro.
Sorry, one little thing.
The fear not, young programmers
thing, that's insulting.
Young programmers aren't afraid.
COLT MCANLIS: But that's my bit.
JOANNA SMITH: It's your bit?
It's wrong.
It's insulting.
It's mean.
COLT MCANLIS: Fine.
My name Colt McAnlis and
this is Compressor Head.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You know, by now I
think that we've all
understood that variable length
codes aren't exactly optimal.
Consider if you
wanted to compress
all of the books in English
Dictionary, all 26 volumes.
Sure, we could just
run through, create
a VLC for the whole thing,
and then compress it,
but that's just not optimal.
See, the single tome for
words that start with Q
would have generally
more Q's in it than any
of the other tomes combined.
As such, the efficiency of codes
used for the other books of A
and Z would be offset by the
abundance of Q's in the tome
of Q's.
Sounds like my new band.
Anyhow, sure you could, with
the right foreknowledge,
simply compress 26
separate streams,
but we can't assume
that all data streams
will be so well behaved.
What we really need is a
way to encode our data that
takes locality into account, but
it's almost impossible for us
to pick those dividing points
given the fact that we're
taking the whole stream
from a high level view.
The trick is this, we don't pick
a split point ahead of time.
Now instead we use
a dynamic method
of encoding that
let's us know when
we should be splitting
our stream appropriately.
And this, my friends,
is the definition
of adaptive statistical
compression.
It's a crazy algorithm that lets
your coding stream reset itself
if things get too out of hand.
So let's take a look.
Break.
Go.
Now typically there
are three stages
to a statistical compressor.
Number one, walk
through the stream
and calculate probabilities.
Number two, assign
variable length codes
to symbols based on
their probability.
And then number three, walk back
through the stream and output
the appropriate code
word for each symbol.
It basically means
you have to do
two passes through the
stream and have one VLC table
for the entire set of data.
Now the adaptive version of
this collapses all three steps
into a single one.
The key to that
functionality lies
in the symbol to code
word table not being
set in stone as we're encoding.
Instead it updates itself
as we encounter symbols.
Basically it works like this.
Read in a symbol, output
it's variable lengths code,
and then update the VLC table.
But this is a little complex.
Let's try to look at an example.
Let's say we've got a VLC table
that looks just like this.
Now let's say we read
in the next symbol
from our input
stream, which is a B,
so we would then output the 1
0 value to our output stream.
And we would need to then go
and update our probabilities.
The next symbol, again,
is a B. So we once again
output a 1 0 to
the output stream.
And we're going to go ahead
and update our probabilities
one more time.
So let's see this goes to 40%
here and this goes to 50% here,
and one doesn't need to be used.
Now notice what
happened here though.
Since B suddenly became
the dominant symbol
it now should have the
shortest code word.
So this should go to 1 0.
This should go to 0.
And this should
stay at 1 1, well,
we got an extra
sticky out of it.
So if the next symbol we read
off the line was actually
a B 0 would be output
to our output stream,
rather than the 1 0 before.
This allows our stream to
dynamically update and reassign
the shortest symbols to the
most probable code words,
even as the frequencies change
in our encoding process.
Now the decoder will work
in the opposite form.
It reads the
variable length code,
checking each step
against its current table.
Once it finds what it's
looking for it emits a symbol,
updates the VLC table,
and then continues on.
Now let's look at
that in action.
So we say we've got this
updated VLC table here.
Let's get of these.
We don't need those anymore.
Let's say we've got this VLC
table and we read in a 1 0
from our stream to decode.
Of course, this then translates
to emitting a B to our output
stream.
And we need to, of course,
update our probability
since we've seen a new symbol.
This goes to 40%.
This goes to 50% and this
goes to 10% once again.
And once again B actually has
become the most dominant symbol
and we need to change our
code words accordingly.
So this should go here.
This should go here.
And this should go here.
And look at that.
As long as our decoder is
updating its symbol table
in the same fashion
that the encoder is
the two will always be in sync.
This is the basic process of
how adaptive statistical coding
works.
The encoder and decoder
are both dynamically
updating their probability
tables for symbols,
which affects compression.
This is a very simple
idea in theory,
but you need two other
items to make it work right.
[LAUGHTER]
JOANNA SMITH: That was unfair.
COLT MCANLIS: But
one caveat here
is what happens when we
encounter a symbol that we
haven't seen before.
There's effectively no
entry in the VLC table
for us reference so we can't
directly admit a symbol.
I mean, we could hypothetically
update our table first,
so then we could output a
1 1 to the output stream,
but this actually creates
another whole problem
too because the decoder itself
would get super confused.
I mean, it would see the
1 1 on the output stream
and think it's two
B symbols in a row,
since it hasn't been told
to update the VLC tables.
So we'd need some way
to signal the decoder
to add a new symbol
to the stream
before updating
its table so we can
stay in sync with the encoder.
This can be done with the
help of a new code that
can be admitted to our stream.
Anytime we encounter
a new symbol
we output a literal
code to the output,
followed by the 8-bit
ASCII of our input symbol.
Only after this point do we
update the stats in our VLC
table, but the lingering
question is what should we
use for the value of literal?
I mean we can't just choose a
random set of bits or anything
that violates the prefix rule.
Instead what we have to do
is initialize out VLC table
with a fake symbol that
represents literal.
When we encounter a symbol
from the token stream
that we haven't seen
before we first output
a VLC for the literal token
followed by the eight bits
for the new symbol.
And then just like normal we
have to go through and update
our table and
probabilities accordingly,
reducing the probability
of the literal symbol.
The decoder, when it
sees the literal token,
will first read in
the next eight bits
and add the symbol to the table
and update the probabilities
accordingly.
Effectively this allows
our encoder and decoder
to handle adapting
to new symbols
that they haven't seen before.
That's good.
Ow. [BLEEP] dude.
Now as we've talked
about before,
as your adaptive stream
adjusts to new symbols that
are being added to it the
code word lengths will change
and you'll eventually
hit a point
where the output
stream is diverging
from the suggested entropy
by a specific amount.
For example, let's
take this phrase here.
As we're encoding it we can
track the suggested entropy
against the results of an
adaptive VLC implementation.
Now in order to allow our stream
to effectively split itself
for better compression
we need to allow
it to define a point in
which you can reset itself
so that future sections
can get better encoding.
Now you can see that
for this example string
we end up with the encoded
output where each symbol is
about 1.1 bits larger than
the suggested entropy,
resulting in a stream that's 26
bits larger than it should be.
But the truth is that if
we split the string in half
and encode each one
separately, we'd
end up with a lower entropy and
smaller encoded output, which
yields a stream that's only 22
bits larger than the suggested
entropy stream.
To do this we employ
the same tactic
that we had with the literals
and create a reset token
in our variable table.
Any time this symbol
exists in the stream
it signals the
encoder or decoder
to reset its current VLC
tables and start fresh,
which is pretty straightforward.
However, the real
trick then is knowing
when to emit a reset token.
See, as we're
outputting code words
we can keep track of the
suggested entropy of the input
stream and the actual bits per
symbol of the output stream.
If the output size
starts diverging
from entropy by a
significant amount
we can use this cue to emit
a reset token, at which point
the stream resets and starts
fresh just like normal.
Applying this technique
for large streams
is critical to
ensure that you're
staying as close as
possible to entropy even
though the probability
of the symbols
will change as you process
more symbols on the stream.
JOANNA SMITH: I mean, this--
Well, that works.
COLT MCANLIS: See?
I told you.
Listen, it was never
a the algorithm.
It was all about the data set.
By taking advantage of
the locality of our data
we're able to optimize the
tables more efficiently, which
means that we're going to
get better compression.
This is the whole point of a
dynamic statistical-- wait.
Where are you going?
I mean, we've got to talk
about the dynamic Huffman
and dynamic arithmetic--
JOANNA SMITH: Some of
us have real work to do.
COLT MCANLIS: Oh.
Well, thanks for stopping by.
JOANNA SMITH: Grow some hair.
COLT MCANLIS: My
name is Colt McAnlis.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]